[Music]
let's
begin so we are 15 19
15 19. uh the games have become
far more competitive and let's get the
show on the road
we're playing tuvish tushenbot from
mongolia
all right well let's go e4 let's go e4
and we've been experimenting with the
open sicilian
uh in in the 10-minute speed run i'm a
little bit tired of the c3 sicilian so
let's play mainline stuff let's play
open sicilian which means d4
and knight takes d4 and let's test the
guy on some theory
okay so e5 is i think called the
kalashnikov
um i think this is or the lowenthal
now you might see this and say i've seen
this before somewhere isn't this the
sveshnikov
it's not quite the specimen of the
savashnikov has the inclusion of knight
f6 knight c3 and then e5
the uh there are similar ideas in this
line but
the uh but the theory itself is
different and there's quite a few
differences as well
now where should this knight go uh
where should this knight go and it's the
same square if you know the theory of
the sfeshnikov it's
it's exactly the same idea the point is
that e5 weakens the d6 square
and we want this knight to have
immediate access to that square so
knight to b5
now black has a couple of moves here
there's a6
and there's d6 d6 covers the square a6
chases the knight
and essentially forces knight d6 check
and there's some theory that i'll show
you guys there
but queen a5 check is not a move that's
definitely not a move thank you take him
in
definitely not a move um okay now that's
a pretty weird
yeah so that doesn't do anything it
doesn't attack the knight because our
bishop defends the night that's one of
the that's one of the points
now how should we block this check
that's a pretty instructive moment
i think that this is a bit of a trick
question
because a lot of you guys i think will
have the
instinct of blocking with the bishop
because it attacks the queen
but one of the general takeaways
has has been that you want to be careful
about
making a move just because it has a
threat you also want the move to be
independently good
the problem with bishop d2 let's say his
queen even moves back to d8
he admits his mistake take a look at
that bishop on d2
right um is it a well-placed bishop
no it's not right it's obstructing the
queen's control over d6 we're gonna have
to move that bishop again
so let's just go knight c3 this doesn't
create a threat but we want the knight
on c3 and if he goes a6
we still have this possibility of going
96 chad
well he can't take my knight the knight
is defended
oh you're joking funny okay bishop b4
all right so he tries to pin the knight
and we have a pretty wide
wide choice here um
the instinct i think for a lot of us is
to go
a3 and chase the bishop away and
terminate the pin
but that's not strictly necessary he
isn't
really threatening anything he isn't
really threatening anything so we could
we could play knight d6 check and try to
force him into taking that knight and
then
sinking our queen into d6 that looks
great a3 looks pretty good as well to be
honest
because a3 does threaten to atta to take
his bishop
and i want you guys to stop and meditate
on that for a second
what i just said may seem wrong why does
a3 threaten to
to capture the bishop doesn't the rook
hang at the end of the line
right sky bobbles to your point so if
you fork if you
visualize that position he's got no
pieces developed he's got all these
holes
and the simplest is then to go knight c7
check and fork his work but even without
that
white is an overwhelming initiative if
we just go knight d6 check i'll show you
guys after the game
so i like the move a3 from that
perspective
let's try it let's play a3 let's see
what he does because if he plays a move
like knight f6 okay so he does take
now i'm not moving and you guys might be
like why are you not moving obviously
you should take with the knight
is it obvious that we should take with
the knight and maybe we will i haven't
decided yet but is it obvious that we
should take with the knight
king e2 right exactly king e2 is a
genius move
no the answer is no we have an
alternative we're going to play this
alternative
what is the alternative and who can
explain why it's
compelling why is it compelling to take
with a pawn
because we have the idea of going knight
d6 and that's completely unstoppable
he cannot protect that square now why is
96 so good his 96 forces his king to
move
and i'll show you guys the game
afterward this knight on d6 is going to
completely terminate his ability
to develop the bishop the knight is
going to be like an elephant on his
on his chest and he's just not going to
be able to
to make a single move and
is it worth ruining our pawn structure
over that absolutely it is
and i've been making this point
consistently for a while now
ruining your queenside pawn structure is
not such a big deal in the first place
because you're probably going to castle
king's side
so that's still safe the one time that
you should be
most worried about ruining your pawn
structure
is in the event that you're going to
castle
to that spot and here you're not going
to castle queenside
queen d6 is very much possible too queen
d6 and knight c7 it depends on what he
does
depends on what he does
depends on what he does king he said
well now that
literally asks for trouble here of
course knight d6 what he's trying to do
is take the sting out of knight d6
but obviously he well he walks into
queen d6
if he goes here that'll lead to a nice
little finale
ladies and gentlemen i'm all ears
what should we do
the triumph of our strategy checkmate to
his majesty
and twofon goes down that's the fastest
speedon game i've played
that's kind of cool actually so
yeah so the low and thaw variation does
not turn out well for our opponent
i'm gonna pour the t i've have i i think
i've earned i've earned some tea after
that
right and then we're going to look at
the game
all right so um this movie 5
i think i've even played as feshnikov as
black on the stream
so you guys are familiar with with this
fashion cobble a little bit right e5
carlson plays it it's one of the most
topical openings
uh for for several decades now and the
lowenthal
has has you know it's flown a little bit
under the radar and it's not bad
you know this game is not a faithful
representation of of this line
um geary just played it against nepo
yeah right
oh he played the did he play the low
enthalpy he played this fashion card i
assume he played this fashionable
so knight b5 um especially i'm named
after
genny's fashion cup i played special cop
in blitz actually
a couple of years ago in riga so that
was a cool experience he's in his 70s
the lowenthal was played for the first
time
uh and that is named after jacob
lowenthal who even played morphy who's
one of the strongest european players of
the 19th century
and in a rare so lowenthal was not the
first to play the law until de la
bourdine
was the first to play in a match against
mcdonald that was a very famous match
in 1824 the strongest british player at
the time played the strongest
strongest fringe player at the time and
um i'm curious if you guys can uh solve
a little historical riddle
what move do you think mcdonald like put
yourself in the shoes of somebody who
lived in 1824 knew
not too much about you know the sort of
inner workings of positional chess he
wasn't bad
what do you think mcdonald played here
in response to e5
yeah so he took the knight right because
that's what you're taught to do right
you're not
knight b5 is a move that you play if you
have a keen understanding of you know
how these weak squares work and stuff
so knight c6 happened all three times
that that
uh de la bourdain played the match uh
played the the lowenthal and
uh and this happened and this is of
course very good for black because d5 is
super easy to orchestrate um
then the first person to play knight b5
uh didn't do so until 1862. blackburn
joseph henry blackburn
so the brits redeemed themselves um
you know the brits redeemed themselves
about 40 years later with blackburn
playing knight b5
now after an ip5 black has a couple of
moves
d6 is the main one with 20 000 games
a6 is also a very interesting line
and a6 leads to knight d6 check takes
takes and generally i think black plays
queen f6 here tries to get this queen
out of d6 obviously
and i think the white's supposed to be
slightly better
uh but the advantage is not vast they're
they this isn't like
crazy and there's also queen e7 queen e7
is is also a way of trying to get the
queen away and usually white just
retreats and just says you know i have
the two bishops and i have control over
this square
so you could get a position like this
and white's slightly better
but black's position is very very solid
um
but that doesn't tell the whole story d6
is the main move queen a5 track
misses the point completely i do think
that he that he missed that the knight
was not hanging i think that's where it
that's where it originated from yeah he
was over 2500 at the time
and yeah so once again bishop d2 we
don't want to play because it obstructs
the queen's
control over d7 and the queen could just
even drop back to d8
so knight c3 bishop b4 a3
and um you know what were the
alternatives
we could have gone here and reached this
position
obviously big advantage for white but a3
is a very tantalizing move that faces
black with a lot of difficulties as we
saw
once again if he goes knight f6 then we
take and he takes
this is very much possible white is up a
piece and crushing but not the only move
right in this position you could just
play knight d6 check
and the simplest move just the absolute
simplest move what would be can
somebody's
name a simple approach to playing this
position with white because remember
you're not even in any hurry black is
not going to develop the pieces
so we can just casually develop our own
pieces
and pile up on this pawn for example
bishop c4 being a good move
then we can castle and then we can play
f4 to open the f file and just
that is totally and absolutely crushing
and this knight on d6 and the sicilian
is a devastating piece particularly
since black
you know the bishop can't come out this
way either
and i had a very nice game in a
different variation of the sicilian
back when i was in i am which showcased
a similar concept i can show you guys
really really fast
it was against ukrainian grand master
andrei wafk
and this was one of my nicest games i
won't go through it in any kind of depth
uh in too much depth around there but
it's it's
it's nice yeah so this is essentially
the tournament right after i became a gm
and this was a rosalina bishop b5 so i
didn't play open sicilian
but what eventually happens he goes e5
so you can see the same d6 square being
weakened
and i get my knight to diesel so i
sacrifice upon
uh to crash open the center then i i'm
able to get a knight to d6
and we get a very similar type of
situation where
i swing my queen around to a3 uh just to
keep the queen side
supervised and i just crushed him here
he he never
got his pieces out properly now there
was a lot of subtleties here
i maneuvered my pieces very successfully
and then i shut down the center even
further
eventually we reached this position
and really cool tactics happened
starting here this was
again one of my nicer combinations so
i've gotten all my pieces involved
this pawn on d3 is a little bit annoying
and what's even more annoying is that if
i take this pawn on d3
black plays knight takes c5 removing the
protection from this knight on d6
and in the complications black is
actually fine
so in this position i spotted a very
pretty move
that transforms my advantage into a
crushing attack could anybody find it
this is not an easy move and i hope you
guys are okay with me showing this so
bishop h6 you're on the right track
the move is knight to f5 and the point
is that if he takes the knight
bishop h6 happens and he might look well
f6 f6 defends the bishop but no f6 is
illegal because he's pinned
uh and there's no way to defend the
bishop so this attacks the queen the
queen has to move
now we grab the bishop and now look at
his king it's so wide open now i take a
moment to take on d3
just to get this pawn out of the way and
my opponent goes knight takes e5
the last desperate attempt that's a very
pretty tactical
uh resource now what the hell is this
who can spot his idea
against bishop take c5 what is what is
he doing
is he just going to move his king and
give everything up
it's kind of cool he goes queen takes e5
and it's a funny situation if you take
the rook
well he can take either rook and he's
fine and if you take the queen
you take and well black is just up upon
in the end game that's totally not what
we want
if you take the rook first he takes the
queen and again black is totally fine
here
so i saw this move and
you know simply retreated my queen to e3
he his rook is hanging and his knight is
hanging so he has to take the rook
but now i take the knight in the
intermediacy and after f6 he had
calculated up until this point thinking
that he's fine
this is where i managed to out calculate
him without the next move
black is completely very much alive here
white to play always look for
intermediate moves in these
sorts of positions your tactical sensors
have to be activated
and if you realize that you're losing
the bishop anyway bishop takes f6 is
quite simple
he can't take with the rook you take
with the queen you take the queen he has
to stick with the king
i come back to take the rook exposing an
attack on his queen
and now after queen d had a very
important move his king wants to come
back to g7 he will be lost anyway
but i dropped my queen on h6 just to
make sure his king
tightening the noose around his king and
the noose has tightened further with
queen h4
the point being if king g7 the rook
comes into e7 with mate
goes king f5 and he resigned after g4
king f4 comes rookie four and i will
deliver checkmate so he resigns after
after g4
there was there were some details that i
missed here but the bottom line is that
this
this entire combination stemmed from my
knight being on d6
and preventing him from uh from
breathing properly
okay um coming back to the
speed run it's the same general
principle albeit in a more
one-sided position he goes bishop c3 we
go bc by now you guys should understand
why it is so important to get this
knight here as quickly as possible
knight to d6 is coming
and yeah and queen d6 of course i mean
he should have gone king e8 but now
now we have to be careful but this is
fine
takes takes he takes on c3 and here
last question to you guys what should
white do
how should white respond to this check
this is important
you have to be very attentive to the
tactical details here
and i dropped okay yeah not bishop d2
because black takes with track but king
to d1
understanding that this is going to be
checkmate tabby's cyclone 7 thank you
for the pride
okay let's play one more that was not
very satisfying
now let's decide what we're going to
play with black
let's play a night or we're going to
play a night off i fee i'm in a knight
or foot right now
i want to play knight no d4 there we go
okay so we've been experimenting let's
go to f6 now let's decide what to do
okay let's play something interesting
i'm gonna play something interesting
whatever i'm thinking i'm not gonna play
king's indian we've done that a lot
that would be boring grunfeld i can
entertain a grenfeld
yeah let's do a grunfeld g6 let's do a
grumpfeld
and of course the gronfeld in contrast
to the king's indian is
d5 here rather than d6 the grunfeld
is one of those openings that just is
universally considered to be one of the
best objective defenses against d4
nobody has found an advantage against
the ground field anywhere
the downside of it is that the amount of
theory that you have to remember as
black
if you want to play this at a
professional level is absolutely out of
this world
now you don't have to know this there
you can play the grunfeld and not know
that much
but someone like mvl who plays the
grunfeld and the night or
you can understand the amount of
maintenance work that you have to put in
so i'll explain the general ideas
afterward
the bottom line is that we're grabbing
control of the center
and we're we're combining the king's
indian ness of the fianchetto but
instead of letting y play e4
we're proactively playing d5 all right
so bishop f4 is a legitimate
uh continuation now we don't want to
take this pawn that's not in the spirit
of the gruntful the point is not to grab
the pawn the point is to develop very
quickly
so that we could attack white's center
it's also a hyper modern opening
so we go bishop g7 here
yeah we go bishop g7 so c6 is
unnecessary we are okay with white
we are okay with bringing our queen out
to d5
we are totally okay with that knight
takes d5
you're joking okay
all right
no bishop f4 is is a legitimate line
cd in com in combination with this is
not great
because now now
white's main continuation is to take and
then play e4
but with the bishop on f4 the bishop
will be hanging so he's mixed up two
lines
now his center immediately comes under
some fire
okay bishop g3 is is i think correct
and one of the things that makes the
grunfeld
both fun to play but also hard to play
is the the tactical alertness
i'll explain that after the game uh dark
knight rises the answer is i mean
kind of but we would sacrifice it
um so let me just
let me write that down
yeah so what makes the grunt felt so
hard to play among other things
is that you have to be on your toes and
on your heels
constantly for uh these
all these tactical ideas that you have
to be aware of and one of them is
is the understanding that these
centralized pieces
are um are integral to black's central
strategy
and there's a constant uh attempt here
a lot more tactically than in the king's
indian the king's indian you're playing
the long game you're not really
assaulting white center here you are
and the way that you are is often by
playing various moves like
c5 or knight c6 you're constantly
attacking white center
and white can lose some very quick games
if he doesn't develop very precisely so
between c5 and knight c6 which of
the two moves do you guys think i should
play which of them seems to be a more
effective way
to immediately harass white's center
it's c5 because knight c6 can be met
with e3
creating a pawn train but c5 is very
strong
because if he takes what happens if he
simply takes on c5
what happens if he plays dc so we play
knight take c3
okay so he can trade queens and then he
loses a piece
because he cannot take back bishop takes
c3 happens for king
the king and the rook
and you might say well no problem he can
play e3 here right depend upon
but after the trade he gets an isolated
queen pawn and we're blockading the
square in front of it which is great for
us
that's a phenomenal position for black
what he should do
is probably take the knight first and
then take the pawn
he takes the pawn so unless i
miscalculated here we are in great shape
knight takes c3 wins
basically wins the game
yeah he miscalculated something i don't
know what it is maybe he thought he had
a check here but then we take
that's it that was
a nice introduction to the grunfeld
and you can see you know when faced with
openings that they're familiar with
people in this rating range really
you know don't always handle things well
and
he takes so he he makes things worse but
at this point it's already over
it is very difficult to play the
grenfell you it's not a kind of opening
you pick up casually
which is why at the high level there
aren't as many people who play it full
time not because it's bad but because
there is just
such a vast amount of theory to remember
okay let's get our knight out
e4 okay so we need to just develop our
pieces perhaps get the king out of the
center
this bishop on ca where should we put it
what seems to be a good
approach to developing this bishop and
in the grunfeld even when we're not up a
rook
this is a good square for the bishop
it's not g4 bishop g4 doesn't do
anything
that's what you need to understand it's
it's not about developing a piece
as far into your opponent's territory as
possible but it's more about
understanding what the role should be
this attacks a2 it's sort of centralized
it prevents white's bishop from coming
out to c4 which is really nice
this should be five we can take the pawn
but we don't need to since we're up a
rook i would
i would much rather prioritize peace
play as you often do in the grenfell
and there's many good moves here one
approach is to target the c5 pawn and to
realize that the c5 pawn is a
conduit toward his king so we can begin
by playing rook to see it we could have
also got knight d4 but let's uh
let's cook up knight d4 so it's stronger
when it is played
rook c8 nice job sweet d and then we're
going to go knight d4 rook takes the
puff we're going to go for a mating
attack here we're not even going to
bother with all of the trades well i
guess we are yeah let's go knight d4
anyway right bishop can come back to
capture the knight
notice that he does have rook d1 if he
wants it but then we take on c5 just in
time
eliminating this bishop
um when is it good to learn the grunfeld
well first of all you don't have to
learn it at any level i've
i played it only a couple of times in
tournament play
and i never really you know
had the discipline to learn the theory
it's it's it fits my style
but i would say if you want to learn it
i would say at a minimum
two thousand i i wouldn't i wouldn't
play it unless here
honestly unless you're you're 2000 and
over i think it's
it's so theoretical it's so
um concrete that
you know i just don't think it's worth
it you might win some quick games
if you learn it earlier but you'll be
building the wrong habits then
i think that's just my opinion
but svidler's chest of course i mean if
you want to pick it up and you're 1700
don't let my words stop you don't say
well daniel said this
use your own judgment you've got to be
in charge of your own chess development
i'm not
you know i don't know the secrets of the
universe
all right so what should we do we i
don't think we can save this bishop
i don't think we can save this bishop
which is kind of funny if we go rook b4
here to develop
to defend the bishop what will white do
what will white do
if we play rook before just as a quick
tactical question
not well a three guy's a three just rook
a4 a3 you're rushing
he just resigns a3 there's two options
first of all is just rook a4
second of all we can stick the bishop on
b3 with check the move is bishop e5
bishop b5 attacks the rook and attacks
the bishop
but what will we do well probably f6 is
a good move
walk the king over to f7 put the rook on
c8 and win
easily all right
so
the grunfeld little history as usual
grunfeld was a uh i think
german i'm not sure what his nationality
was maybe austrian aaron
grunfeld a very long chest career
you know very strong chess player and uh
theoretician obviously developed the
gruntful developed other openings as
well
um and this was probably around the year
the first time it was played was 1855.
the second time it was played was by
alex it was by alekhine
alekhine was the second player to play
it and then grenfell played it
uh three times in 1922.
austrian he was austrian now the funny
thing is grenfell plated to
beat to beat alec
grenfell played it to beat alekhine in
vienna 1922 which is quite amazing to
beat al qaeda with black
granfield was the first person to really
show the main ideas though when alekhine
played it he just was sort of
screwing around thank you bag of candles
then alakine played it in 1923 and and
beat somebody and grunfeld continued to
play it
um sort of throughout and alakine really
took a liking to it so
um it caught on as early as the 1930s
lots of people started playing it
bobbinic people understood that this was
a very serious opening
and white players also understood that
the best way to meet it
was to take and immediately control the
center with e4 so in contrast to the
king's indian
what's the similarity similarity is
you're giving white control of the
center
right unequivocally white stingy
california i think of the three months
white has control of the center and and
it is a hyper modern opening in the
sense that you develop your pieces you
feel ghetto your bishop
with an eye toward eventually attacking
the center from a distance
and the main instrument of attack in the
center is of course this move c5
c5 aims to break down the pawn on d4
and in addition to c5 black has knight
c6 and bishop g4 and all these ways
to turn up the dial and attack the pawn
on d4 and try to get it to move
the for that reason white's main line is
to go bishop c4
c592 this is the old main line it still
is
very much reputable what's the point of
this the point of this is that if black
goes bishop g4 at some point
white's going to have f3 making sure
that the knight is intact and making
sure that the pawn on d4
is well protected this bishop will come
out to e3
now if i please e5 then this pole pawns
chain is going to be overextended so
black's going to take and go knight c6
and attack this
and you'll have a hole on d5 the black
can occupy
so there's a lot of nuance here that i
won't get into
um what if they take your e-pawn
not sure where okay
i won't get into the nuance bishop f4 is
i think it's called the it's called the
brinkman attack
and the best way to continue for white
is just to play e3 not to take the pawn
at all
this is the proper theoretical
continuation
generally speaking black castles and
oftentimes black goes c5
ground field is a very tactical opening
you often sacrifice two pawns and go
like this
things get crazy so there is
probably nine or 10 reputable
counters to the grenfell which is
mind-boggling
but our opponent takes and we had a
question about
taking on c7 now if you don't know
anything about the grenfell you might
believe that the best approach is just
to take the pawn back
but a gruntful player won't do that
gruntful player will say
i would much rather develop my pieces
quickly
and go for a quick attack on the king
then
bend over backwards to win the spawn
back so black and just castle
or go knight c6 and this bishop is also
very awkward you're gonna have to waste
the tempo bringing the bishop back
for example e3 e3
let's say knight c6 and
you know in a situation like this black
could already consider e5 blasting open
the center
you guys kind of get the point black
gets full compensation for the pawn
there are lines in the grunfeld
where black sacrifices upon or sometimes
even two pawns for this kind of
quick development now 2000 is a number
i'm really pulling out of my behind
and you know
you can try it out you can see how it
how it treats you and whether you're
succeeding with it you can get svidler's
course when it's on sale and
and try your luck it's not going to hurt
okay well mvl plays it because he's
a machine
mvl and svidler are probably the top two
super gm grunfeld
specialists
all right so our opponent plays bishop
g3 we go c5
he should have taken the knight first
and then taken the pawn
and in this position black has black has
solved all the opening problems rook c1
it's important to recognize that you
have this check but after queen d2
i mean black is slightly better here
i've got a beautiful bishop the king is
weak but white can play
so i i feel like this is what he should
have done to limit the damage but after
yeah after dc knight c3 the game is over
any questions about this game well
magnus has a much
wider repertoire than mvl and vl plays
grenfell night almost exclusively
yeah magnus plays everything and
magnus's repertoire is closer to what
most super gms do now
mvl is very uncommon at the top level is
ambient at a disadvantage well that's
the big question right
the answer was to that was no but things
have turned
starting with tata steel recently where
people started beating him in the night
or
and the power of preparation has gotten
to the point
where you know people like fabi's team
works for months to
to break down mbl's repertoire is
incredible
it's survived for many many years he's
won tons of games in the grunfeld and
the night or
but you know he might have to widen his
repertoire a little bit to make himself
a little more unpredictable so it's
it's not a one or a zero
[Music]
you